the real rejects can confer for this
five pointer but if they miss it ATC
wins the game Oh Christian the drama's
never been more intense who played tango
and who played cash we're talking this
over roots they really have learned the
art of the game very quickly the need to
play its hang on cap yeah who played
tango my clitoris epic actors make her
rustling yeah right yes that's the
quickly you got five four three two
muscles like tango and
you know John even though we lost the
movie trivia Schmo down I still think we
went the distance yeah
like Rocky Balboa oh good reference I'm
gonna take a piss all right stand here
wait for you get done man's gonna be all
right
where's Oprah lies with
what
and that Gregg just stay away from there
now stay away from here now Joe don't
come in here the [ __ ] you talking about
hey just go go go back your bed don't
come in so you're the boss to the box
no no mummy mummy
maybe once the bark
Gaeta [ __ ] you [ __ ] our soccer
you
you
you're tearing me apart Lisa